all right mr. Bowman aye sir like I
mention I'm such a huge fan of yours
your tick-tocks have been such a source
of entertainment especially well I've
been cooped up at home right you study
theater and media production and now
you've channeled that into these amazing
hilarious tick tock videos what's up MTV
welcome to my crib okay come on many of
them parody reality TV how excited are
you that you've been able to you know
use your craft but also entertain so
many people during this time um I feel
very very lucky I feel like you know I'm
in a very very privileged situation
because I just graduated you know so
many of my friends are like I don't know
what I'm gonna do I have nothing to do
and I feel like I've had too much to do
almost it's been very overwhelming but I
also I feel like it's such a unique
experience because the amount of
messages that I've been getting that
people I've been like making their
quarantine and I'm I'm making people
laugh and it's getting them through I
feel as though I'm I'm a doctor but I'm
still like doing my part to help and
it's it's been a life-changing
experience how would you say the
quarantine in particular has kind of I
don't know influence your content when I
started making tic TOCs
I when I had the idea for these reality
TV tik toks
I was watching Vanderpump rules like the
Vanderpump rules reunion now you're
sitting there and I was like this is so
dumb this is so like whatever they're
arguing about is like so miniscule
Oh should we go there and I sat there
thinking to myself like I wish I had the
time to be arguing with people about
these minut problems and then I was like
well why don't I just make the time now
so that's what we're these reality TV
videos came from and then one quarantine
happened it was almost as if everybody
had time to focus on these my new
problems but a little bit yeah your
sister stealing your chips so I'm
feeling a bit hungry and I go to get
some of my chips ELISA are you eating my
chips
oh my god right now no I didn't know I
was living with a delinquent anarchist
those chips were your day that was
everything to you like why not get very
upset over the top reactions and and I
feel like people are really relating to
that
what's the behind-the-scenes secret we'd
be surprised to know like about your
videos or the process of making that
about - in secret they're not scripted
why don't script anything I think people
are like people think that I plan it out
but really all I have is like the idea
the general idea and we just improv
things I'll say things in the moment and
I'm like I cannot believe I just said
that but it makes so much sense now
there's a huge audience that you've
built right and flaunt magazine even
just named you one of their lgbtqia+
tick tock creators or Trailblazers I
should say I mean what does it mean to
represent that specific part of your
identity yeah you know what it's so
weird you know what I when I was I mean
I am I'm Jen Z I'm not some old I'm not
old but even when I was in high school
there was nobody on TV that looked like
me about does my sexuality that sounded
like me nothing even on YouTube but now
to be a tick talker and my sexuality has
never mattered it's never even been a
question nobody really asks me about it
it doesn't really I don't have to make
videos about it it just the fact that I
you know can be known for really
anything at this point
online is I think is a huge step in the
right direction and I'm feel very very
privileged to be in this situation it's
very very cool it's so cool and
obviously it comes at a time where there
is a really low tolerance for any
discrimination based on race sex gender
sexual identity and when visibility
really matters you know
and of course LGBTQ is just one part of
your identity on your Instagram profile
literally the bio says and I want to get
this right a Spaniard in a Jamaican walk
into a bar then they had me
obviously that's an odds here at the
background but like how has all these
different parts that make you you kind
of shaped your content or what you've
set out to do just in life in general
you know you know what I have always
been reminded that I was different
my entire life and but I've never looked
at it as a bad thing even when other
people did I never saw it as a bad thing
I always saw it as my differences make
me very cool I like my name even my mom
because my mom is an immigrant from
Spain and her part of Spain is like
Celtic so she gave me a Celtic name
Bowman and I've never met another Bowman
I feel like my entire life I've been
living up to the name Bowman like how do
you do that yeah
though I feel like I've always had this
this mindset that's I'm different but
people love that about me and if I
believe in that then hopefully I can
convince others that they can believe in
that in themselves as well to also have
been handed a million followers last
month was like okay now I have a
platform what do I say and I'm one of
these issues I mean yes I am biracial
but it's also like I grew up in a white
family predominantly white family I grew
up with white kids in my high school my
friends are a lot of white kids I I was
also being woken up to a lot of the
realities that are in America and in
Canada so it was very very challenging I
feel like I had to confront a lot of
different problems a lot of different
things that I had never really thought
about but it's been a journey it's been
a very big journey
obviously June is Pride Month and as an
lgbtq+ trailblazer
what does pride mean to you especially
during this time especially this year
pride you know what if you had asked me
last year I would have said pride is
about twerking on the street during the
parade and going getting drunk and going
to the club yeah I've learned it's not
it but yeah
yes you know what I think this pride has
been a very special one it's been a very
self-reflecting pride and just realizing
you know what what it is that actually
matters about being part of the LGBTQ
community and I think it just is about
being proud and for me this year I feel
like every other pride has been about
myself and a bit of a journey and
learning about you know who I am but
I've also kind of realized this year
that as much as it is about me it's
about showing everybody else that
follows me that knows who I am and it's
okay to be yourself and whatever you
identify with it's okay and it's okay to
open up conversations and and open up
spectrums and and change the world well
have you learned about yourself amid
this crazy time both dealing with the
global pandemic but also the current
black lives matter too later I used to
think that people wouldn't ever follow
me because I'm not yes I am
biracial but I never thought if I was
black enough
yes I'm queer but I never really thought
I was queer enough but I have just kind
of convinced myself of something that my
mom used to say to me all the time that
kind of just went over my head and it's
that you know you are enough and that I
should tell myself I am enough people
love me for me and I think it's
something that I've just learned is that
I have I've been just really enjoying
relating to people yeah and and learning
that things that I've been going through
my day-to-day and and the way I feel
online and the way I look and this color
of my skin it's not it's unique to me
but it's also the human experience
everybody's going through the same
things at the same time tick tock has
come under fire recently for what
they're calling collaborative filtering
how that is impacting minority
influencers as much as we want to say
like you know this is a tick tock issue
it's also an issue with the user too if
you're tick-tock and you're only seeing
videos of white people the app is gonna
continue feeding things feeding you
things that it thinks that you want
right um the best way to fight that I
think is you have to start the ground up
you have to go find black creators not
just for the sake of finding black
creators but just fine
step out of your comfort zone step out
of your bubble what advice do you have
for put your followers and your audience
who are really trying to find their own
voice or their own place in this world
this whole thing has been a learning
experience for me I realized that I
wanted to act and I wanted to be a
storyteller and entertain and I've just
gone straight down that Pratt path and
never looked back and in doing that I've
learned about how important my voice has
been and it's just about trusting
yourself and telling yourself that
you're enough do you have your sights
set on a career outside of tik-tok like
what's next for you we're gonna make a
pilot no I I don't know I have the goal
keeps changing you know yeah one day
it's like I wanted to be an actor and I
want to do
very dark movies but then the next day
it's like no I wanna watch my show
actually turn into a show and see it on
a streaming platform one day I want to
continue doing what it is that I'm
passionate about and that's storytelling
making people laugh making people feel
good uplifting people yeah and then one
day I'll have my fashion line there you
go right exactly and maybe the palette
to go with it